miracles do happen remote or otherwise
that is the hope that the family members
want me to convey I'm not ready to
concede that he's dead yet
we have not yet been able to recover any
debris
the search involves some of the most
sophisticated equipment known to mankind
and no expense has been spared yep just
going faster from there this
multinational mission bringing together
some of the most powerful forces on
earth but for all their strength in the
air and their powers in the water the
men and women searching for the remains
of flight mh370 have found nothing not a
single piece of debris has been
recovered to solve one of the world's
greatest aviation mysteries
unfortunately we didn't find anything of
significance out there
we arrived first I think there's seven
other aircrafts out there that are still
searching we were focused in an area to
the south that was based around the best
estimates and intelligence that we have
so far the weather in the area was
reasonably good most of the area we were
able to see you know four or five
kilometers or more the sea state was up
however which meant that there were
quite a few Whitecaps in the area so the
crew would have had a bit of people
could see just hearing the difference
between objects in the water and the
Whitecaps so it made it hard for the
guys today
but each sighting is potentially
important Marcus dropped into the ocean
will record movement giving detail of
current direction and speed data that
could prove crucial later for the
objects that that were potentially
started yesterday
they've been there being the position
has been recorded they've dropped drift
boys in the area to try and get an
assessment of what the drift is doing
for those objects and other aircraft in
the area I attempt me to relocate those
Chinese spotters saw this object today
it's undergoing analysis to determine
exactly what it could or could not be
after we flew for about 20 minutes over
the search area we found an orange
object in the shape of an elbow under
the right wing three minutes later we
found another white strip shaped object
we reported this information to the
captain immediately when we detected
these suspicious objects we first tried
to verify the information and we find
that they were located at the extended
line we verified by flying over them
twice we dropped a marker at each
suspicious spot from a height of 300
meters which should correspond with the
objects locations according to your
calculated longitude and magnitude this
satellite image released on Friday is
also one of the latest recordings of
what may or may not be pieces of the
plane that vanished without trace three
weeks ago but for now that is all we
have
yesterday was a better day for searching
today I understand is another good day
for searching the weather conditions are
benign for that rather inhospitable part
of the world yesterday as I understand
it there were visuals from from five
aircrafts of debris in the ocean
unfortunately despite the presence of
some six vessels in and around the new
search area we have not yet been able to
recover any debris so that that task
continues we should not underestimate
the difficulty of this work it is an
extraordinarily remote location these
are these are inhospitable seas it's an
inaccessible place we are trying to find
small bits of wreckage in a vast ocean
and while we are trying everything we
have at it the task that goes on
age aircraft covered more than two
hundred and fifty two thousand square
kilometers today alone again more
objects were seen but again nothing
decisive all I can see is that I can
continue with only with the leaves that
we have at the moment we have six
sightings under satellite the vessels
are going there I believe that there'd
be some visual sightings of the objects
today those I got to wait and get
reports on whether they have retrieved
those objects miracles to happen remote
or otherwise that is the hope that the
family members want me to convey to the
not only to the Malaysian government mas
but to the world at large and if it
means our prayers that's not very
difficult request
Chinese and Australian ships have
retrieved some objects crucial pieces of
the mh370 jigsaw puzzle or yet more
ocean junk
perhaps another painful distraction
giving false hope to search crews and
heartbroken families it's very very
testing for the relatives the loved ones
left behind normally with an air crash
we know within a day maybe two in the
case of airfare if France for for six
six days this is 21 days later this is
an extraordinary mystery unprecedented
in modern times we've found debris in
the ocean it's been spotted by actually
five aircraft after the New Zealand
aircraft spotted it photographs were
taken there they are now being processed
in Canberra by AM SAR they may be
released today possibly tomorrow to
either confirm or not that the debris
they're found is from three seven zero
but despite days of futile searching the
resolve of the crews has not been worn
down instead there is real hope that a
breakthrough is so very close and
instead of scaling down the operation
more resources and assets are being
deployed the Australian Navy frigate
Toowoomba has joined the operation it
brings long stay capability and boosts
the current international fleet of the
area to six ships each one dedicated to
finding that single scrap of evidence no
matter how small that could explain what
actually happened to the Boeing triple7
depending on what they find and we have
a number of ships out there with
different capabilities to lift different
sizes of debris but the aim will be to
recover the items back onto the ship so
that they can first be verified or or
confirmed or denied as being part of the
aircraft but also there will be valuable
items for the subsequent accident
investigation the pinger as I understand
it is certified to operate up until the
the 7th of April we would expect it to
run a little bit longer than that and at
this stage ocean shield if she sails
Monday depending on the weather we would
expect her in the area around two to
three days afterwards but the critical
phase at this this juncture is to find
debris and as much of it as we can if it
is confirmed to be from the aircraft it
will enable a much greater refinement of
that impact point through through the
modeling agencies back in in EMSA and
that having a very accurate start
pointer or as an accurate start point as
we can for the up in research is
actually critical until yesterday the
search had focused on an area one and a
half thousand miles that's two and a
half thousand kilometres off the
southwest coast of Perth in Australia
but new evidence suggested that the
plane may have been traveling faster
than initially thought and yesterday the
search area shifted 700 miles northeast
today more ships and aircraft expanded
the area and continued to comb the
waters was a plane takes off it's being
tracked by primary military radar which
is common practice until it of course
leaves the radar space now we have that
data and I
they're crunching this now with a higher
precision and they figured out that the
plane has been flying slightly faster
than they presumed if you put this
together with the plane being on
autopilot they could reverse-engineer
the flight path with the field which was
available and they came to the
conclusion it has actually gone down
most likely further north we know very
little about military capabilities in
this region at least I I'm not quite
sure about this
in theory military radar should be very
precise and very reliable what I suspect
is that they maybe didn't have either
the height or the speed and they've been
kind of reverse engineering this which
maybe together with the satellite data
now gives a more complete picture the
disappearance of flight mh370 is a
mystery that refuses to yield answers
just going faster from their finding and
recovering wreckage from the plane will
tell us what happened but investigators
will have to go deep underwater to find
out why the planes black box has the
answers
this metal case will have recorded all
the details of the fateful flight and
tell us why instead of making it to
Beijing the jet ended up thousands of
miles of course in the southern Indian
Ocean but the search for the black box
will become much more difficult when it
stops sending out a locator signal the
beacons on the black boxes will last
another 10 days approximately after that
they will require the autonomous
underwater vehicle the bluefin-21
to go down and survey the bottom of the
ocean looking for wreckage where they
find wreckage they'll find the black
boxes the black box will be a huge
advantage if they find it and then they
can if all the floating material has has
indeed moved 1,100 kilometers they can
then go and pick that up later
new calculations suggest the plane was
traveling faster than first thought that
means it ran out of fuel earlier so
that's shifted the search almost 700
miles northeast closer to the Australian
coast more confusion three weeks into
the aircraft's disappearance the
question being asked is how can an
airliner simply vanished a report into
the Air France disaster in 2009 made
several key recommendations to the
airline industry better practice not
just to prevent aviation tragedies but
guidance in how to find planes quickly
following a fatal loss but it seems
Malaysian Airlines like some others has
ignored those hard learned lessons
triggered transmission of the flight
data say there's a catastrophic incident
it's like pushing a mayday on ships
ships have made a buttons literally if
you have a problem and all you can do in
one second is not even pick up your
rating but push a button that sends out
a signal that that ships in trouble you
could also do the same thing either with
a button or automatically whether an
aircraft and then finally deployable
recorders these cockpit voice recorders
and flight data recorders are now
sitting at the bottom of the ocean 3,000
4,000 thousand metres deep when the
plane crash they separated from the
aircraft and floated and then could be
recovered
sadly you see how slow things happen
because on this Malaysian plane none of
these things have been implemented
so while the search for answers goes on
deep into the Indian Ocean investigators
continue to look for clues on land too
early suspicion fell on the flights
captain 53 year-old zaharie ahmad shah
he was an experienced pilot with more
than eighteen and a half thousand flying
hours under his belt
they found this simulator in captain
zaharie's house investigators say that
some date on it has been deleted the
first officer on the flight was Fariq
Abdul Hameed he's 27 years old and
joined Malaysia Airlines in 2007 he was
fairly new to this model of aircraft a
Boeing triple7 200 CCTV shows the two
men going through security on their way
to boarding the flight that evening
we're told they did not specifically
request to fly together it's not even
known if they knew each other every year
an airline pilot will have at least two
formal checks medical checks which
obviously address not only their
physical health but also their mental
health but of course every time they are
doing the job they're being scrutinized
by people when they arrive at the
airport they will encounter security
staff they have to go through the same
checks as airline passengers to get
through to the aircraft when they board
the aircraft a dispatcher will hand the
plane over to them and when they are
seated next to someone else obviously in
the commercial airline there'll be
another pilot next from always watching
them we have to accept there is some
risk in the world for all sorts of
misfortune we believe pilot suicide on
commercial flight is incredibly rare and
it is very unlikely there
any more robust measures of new measures
that we're not currently using would
have picked out there was one or two
cases that have happened in the last
5-10 years but those who knew the
captain refused to accept that he
deliberately caused the plane to crash I
know him very well he will do that he's
a prophet now rather deal with it
it's your family man yes so very loving
family men
going through some troubles it's been
reported a little slow because I've seen
photos of a family which was quite
recent and I'm sticking middle of last
year well twas the September or so they
look like a typical happily married
couple there is a good family a grandson
he's the grandson attention has also
been paid to the planes passengers could
the flight manifest hold the answers
investigators are scrutinizing every
neighborhood almost three weeks after
the planes disappearance we're learning
more about the men women and children
who were onboard this flight people we
were told this week who have no chance
of survival
but the girlfriend of one passenger
refuses to give up hope
Philip would a fifty year old American
was returning to Beijing following a
business trip he was about to leave
China for good to begin a new life with
Sara basic she was at home packing boxes
waiting for him to walk through the
front door when she heard the news well
I'm not ready to concede that he's dead
yet so right now it's a way to help the
world understand how special feelings
and that
you know that plane might be failed with
239 people but each one of those people
has a story to tell and they're all
worth they're all worth saving and and
he especially is worth saving he's a
very unique man and and I think people
have has grown to quite care about him
in this process and they've grown to
care about his parents and his siblings
and his boys who have all rallied
together and maintained positive hope
instead of screaming and yelling or
blaming
Sera's Facebook tribute to Phillip has
now registered more than 1 million
visitors and that's in less than two
weeks I'm incredibly proud of how his
his children have handled this and how
his family has handled it and and and I
hope that he will be proud of what what
I have done to try to keep that positive
process alive I think he would do the
same for me you know what you you can't
just sit back and wait for someone else
to do something for you you have to be
responsible for it and can push it ahead
Sara's heartache is shared by hundreds
of other families waiting for news of
their loved ones
the youngest passenger is two years old
the oldest 76 7 of them are children yet
to reach their fifth birthday
twenty-six-year-old Yuwen Chou is
originally from Mongolia he moved to
study business at Hull University in
England he went back to see his
girlfriend mikdash Mukherjee and his
wife Jia mo Bey had been on a beach
holiday together in Vietnam their two
young sons are waiting for them at home
barbering Kathy Lawton are from
Springfield Lakes in Australia they have
three daughters and they're described as
doting grandparents Paul weeks is a
mechanical engineer he accidentally left
his wedding ring and watch behind at
home as he traveled to Mongolia for work
i drowned wattle Oh on the right is 17
zalien on the left is 18 they were on
their way to school in Beijing the
minister said here in the government are
in the process of looking for the
missing plane and that we still have
reason to hope that there was us
families of the passengers we don't know
whether they are alive or dead but we're
still hoping they're alive because we
still haven't seen any evidence
an unprecedented search on air and sea
continues to look for traces of flight
mh370 but despite all the resources
being thrown at this mission the ocean
refuses to give up its secrets for the
families no plane wreckage means a
miracle is still possible and they
continue to wait hope and pray for their
loved ones to finally come home